hello folks welcome to rational
science and as I said in the description
I'm on the road partly because I've got
arthritis I'm trying to see if I can do
something about it health issues uh you
know you have the Sandman he puts little
grains of sand in little kids eyes every
morning well he does something different
to me he comes in with a baseball bat
beats the crap out of me you know
throughout the night I wake up in the
morning you know with pain all over the
body
anyways uh yeah I got to lay off the
booze and do a little more gym if you do
it the other way around Mother Nature
punishes
you anyways I'm not going to say much
about Extinction today uh except that
you know it looks like we're in some
kind of uh the beginnings of maybe we're
World War II Wars all over the place
okay and not so much that they that
might be to nukes but it's got to have
an effect on the global economy and uh
again here we argue that's going to be
the economy that's going to fail us okay
so uh you know Extinction might come
around fast than faster than you might
think you know maybe some of you think
it's maybe 20 30 years or more down the
road
uh you know it could happen even within
the next 5 years for all we know you
know so uh keep that in mind you know
sleep with one eye open anyways I hope
everybody's uh can hear me okay uh I
would appreciate a confirmation you know
from anyone okay that you can hear me
okay okay so let's begin we're going to
be doing a couple things here today
we're going to be doing once again ether
there's a lot of uh Loose Ends
uh people need to be uh to brush up on
some of the issues related to Ether and
I think we haven't covered the whole
subject okay so uh hopefully we do a
better job today of getting to the nitty
gritty and then we have the subject
matter today which is this uh bending of
light thingy we're going to see if we
can bend light for you today can you
hear me okay thank you appreciate it
okay so let's start with the first one
I'm going to do a little very quick
review of what couple uh fellows out
there ether said and then I'm going to
address what they uh said you know I'm
going to answer them uh I don't like to
leave these things out in the open and
letting people just think whatever they
want no I want to get to the
nitty-gritty you know and uh some of
these
ethers they don't understand the
arguments and so I reinforce it
reinforce it reinforce it if they come
back well they'll listen and understand
hopefully you know and that's all we can
hope for okay so here it is uh eist the
other day said you know he says I can
draw you some kind of medium out of my
mind referring to the ether uh so what
will that serve I don't know what ether
looks like it's all supposed to be
invisible and intangible not being good
at drawing stuff and doesn't mean that
it doesn't exist okay so that those were
his main arguments okay
and uh so let's go through them real
quickly here how we address each one
first one he says you want me to draw
you The Ether yeah I do and he said I
can draw some ether like you drew me
your ropes okay good that's what we want
you know there I drew a rope you can see
it there in front of your eyes that's
more or less what a rope looks like okay
and he says he can draw you some kind of
medium out of my mind just like you drew
the ropes yeah but he he he doesn't do
it you know he he he's not drawing the
either he's not illustrating ether so we
know or understand what he's talking
about we can visualize you know see what
he's talking about right if it's an
object if it's a thing and he says that
Obsession of yours is ridiculous what
will that serve and it serves at these
two purposes okay it determines whether
you understand the fundamentals of
physics and you can show us what's going
on through your mind when you say ether
okay so those are the main points that
uh we want answered we want to make sure
that this all understands
he understands what he's talking about
when he says ether not so much us you
know I mean we want to understand as
well but it starts with him he's the guy
who's proposing ether he's the fell
who's supposed to make sure that every
under everybody out there understands
what he means every time he pronounces
the word ether is it an object is it a
concept is it a thing is it an
abstraction what what is The Ether you
know so you can't use the ether until
you clarify all that you can't begin in
the middle of your movie and say I'm
going to start moving The Ether I'm
going to be doing fluids the fluid flu
flu flow fluid flu flowing fluids and
the fluids that flow you know flu flow
flee
flow no you can't start in the middle of
your your uh discussion your
dissertation you got to start the
beginning you got to present the objects
that's how we do it in
physics okay so he continues he says uh
I don't know what ether looks like okay
so he's he confesses there he doesn't
know what it looks like so that's why
you can't draw yes any more than you
know what your threads look like not
true I mean there's a thread I drew it
for them that's what a thread looks like
just take any string thread wire
whatever that's more or less what we're
talking about some Thin elongated object
period that's it not nothing out of this
out of the uh out of this world nothing
out of the ordinary it's all supposed to
be invisible and intangible remember and
no the word object the definition of the
word object is that which has shape
there's no provision
for uh tangibility or invisibility so uh
it's it serves no purpose to really
bring in tangibility and visibility into
you know uh the uh when analyzing
something such as The Ether we're not
talking about touching or or even seeing
it we're just saying if you're going to
propose the ether as the medium that
mediates gravity and light no problem
but then show us this mediator you know
this mediator okay do you know what air
looks like yeah we do and there you see
I gave two examples one is the air
around the earth it's looks like a ring
in 2D it looks like a shell in 3D and
there you had the asteron pops a
balloons some air comes out of there
right we colorcoded it so you could see
it okay so you know what we're talking
about and both those air and the air in
the balloon and the air around the earth
both have shape in fact everything that
is made out of atoms had better have
shape whether you can see it or not is
irrelevant the question is does it have
shape it's a yes or no type of question
it's the question is not what is the
shape of a blob okay uh I guess you can
answer it's blob
shape okay so uh whenever they say what
is the shape of no that's the wrong
question does it have shape does energy
have shape does field have shape does
Mass have shape does time have shape
that's the question does ether have
shape well the answer is no ether is a
concept that's why it doesn't have shape
that's why he can't draw it he's trying
to draw love he's trying to draw
intelligence conscience you know you
can't draw those things those
words those Concepts okay okay so um he
says not being good at drawing stuff
doesn't mean that it doesn't exist uh
yeah and he dismisses all this as word
salad It Go goes from one ear through to
the next without anything stopping it in
between okay so yeah uh to him these are
just words because he doesn't pay
attention he thinks that uh doing
definitions is known as word salad in
his religion I guess uh semantics you
know word Wizardry whatever uh they
don't do this and that's the big problem
with science today they give you all
these irrational explanations primarily
because they use Concepts as object
objects meaning they haven't really
defined their Concepts as object in
other words they haven't identified any
object they haven't pointed and said
tree Rock House you know and so on they
start using words as if you understood
that they were objects that's the way
it's handled today and that's a big
problem because it's a problem of
communication okay you don't understand
a physical
interpretation because there is no
physical it's all abstract you know it's
it's all mass it's all time you know and
so yeah if you're going to bend time and
move the mass what have you understood
you know and they get away with all that
stuff in mathematical physics but uh the
dissonance are in no better shape you
know you get the electric Universe uh
The Ether is the flat earthers they do
exactly the same thing they don't
realize you have to start by defining
your terms and pointing at the objects
then you can start your presentation no
one does that everybody skips over those
steps well you know what I'm talking
about no we don't okay so please be uh
careful with your language you know and
and point to the objects and Define your
Concepts that's the way it should work
okay so how did this fell and this time
around he sent me a note there and he
put a comment and he says I was going to
draw for you uh my ether but nah you
would still find something negative to
say why would I even bother you're nuts
so uh yeah he ran away with his tail
between his legs and he got the boot I
mean you know essentially he couldn't
defend his uh religion okay his ether
and that happens with all ethers I
haven't seen a single ether is in the
last few years that has come here that
has been able to defend uh either the
definition of ether or or defend ether
as an object as a thing they can't do
either one
because they don't have a definition
they just say it's it's a it's a fluid
it
flows flu flow flow flu okay that's what
they say and what is that I mean I need
to see I need to I need to see what's
flowing what's fluing okay flu
fluing so these people don't do that
they just jump in the middle of the show
and they start you know acting you know
you you you lost the first frames of the
film you don't know what the guy's
talking about you know and uh so this is
the problem and everybody out there has
this not only the The Establishment
mathematical establishment primarily as
well as this okay so they all make the
same error you have to identify the
objects you have to Define your concept
now one fell here he says he says uh
ether would be like the seed of an apple
there is your object a
seed okay like Janny apple seed there
you know plant the seed and all the
trees grow that's that's how they want
it done well what can I tell you I you
know maybe this guy's just bsing okay
that's all he's doing uh maybe he's not
serious okay uh but you know the reason
I put that comment there even if he was
kidding uh is that it reminded me of
this um here let me show it to you
first uh what was this 1999 and you have
astronomy how it all began and you have
Stephen Hawking Oh wrong one Stephen
Hawking and Neil turac explained the uh
universe's origin okay and here uh I
always keep these good
ones says uh see if I see it here says
beginning and the end okay the beginning
and the end so they're going to say talk
about the Alpha and the omega beginning
uh big bang obviously uh crunch is the
Big Crunch at the end I don't know and
then here give peas a chance okay that's
what the article was about and here let
me show you what these fell said okay
here's uh here's the magazine I put it
up here okay it involves these uh
fellows Neil turac Alan goth and Stephen
Hawking okay how it all began there and
they said that uh The Singularity that
was already there looks more or less
like a p okay they call it the p
instanton and there you see it
Singularity instanton and open Universe
okay that's more or less the starting
point and so you know the question is
how did he get there you know I mean did
God put this p in there was he outside
of the universe you know and a lot of uh
religious folk William Lane Craig one of
them uh he says you know what you proved
is God because what you're saying is
that it all started at a singularity and
where did that come from well obviously
the big man right so unless you can uh
get rid of the big man you know I can
put him in there I could say yeah God
made the uh The Singularity how are you
going to deny it I mean God was there
first and he put the singularity what's
wrong with that I mean if these guys are
going to come up with a singularity to
pee
instanton and say that was there well
who put it there and what was outside of
there there that's the issue I mean if
the P contains time space and matter you
know what what's around it and of course
that's the same question as what is
spacetime expanding against you know
this dark energy that's pushing
everything away what is it pushing
against and they say it's an irrational
question it's not a scientific question
we have no way of proving it and it just
is and they give you a whole bunch of
runaround but they never answer the
question what's outside of it they can't
tell you of course they can't because
they can't
conceptualize what's outside if space is
within the P that's the big problem the
main the primary problem okay so uh here
it is this is what uh they said in that
um magazine in the in astronomy says the
reporter asks what does this new
creation model look like good question
what does it look like draw it you know
illustrate it NE Tura well it's small
and round but not perfectly rounded it
has little syles it looks like a p okay
the universe comes out of one formula in
a beautiful way oh yeah they love beauty
great this is the simplest way for
starting the universe the simplest way
of starting the universe so rer asked
how did he get there okay hcky says it's
meaningless meaningless to ask the
question there is no outside the p no
before the P it just is an object
implied by the very laws of physics okay
the this with the wording that they
throw in your face and so the reporter
says uh but what created those laws and
ter answers we don't know how to create
physics from nothing and that's the only
question that they really needed to
answer how did the singularity come into
being and they can and he just says it
there we don't know how to create
physics from nothing and that answers
pretty much all the questions you know
and again when I use my Universal movie
Tool uh to illustrate what Turk and and
Hawking are saying there this is it you
have God right he creates uh something
from nothing and they always take you to
frame two they say there was something
there was a singularity in there might
look like a p like a circle like a ball
we don't care there's something there
but there was nothing you know in frame
number one so how did something come
from nothing with or without God I mean
if you want to put God in there put him
in there I don't care you know just tell
me the mechanism okay how do you create
something from nothing and that's the
only question that anyone who talks
about Big Bang or creationism has to
answer and they never do I mean even the
people who are in favor of God no
problem you want to put God in the
picture I have no Pro I personally have
no problem okay the question is how did
God come into being did he have a mother
was he there forever you know uh did he
come into being I mean I mean you got to
answer that question and you can't say I
don't know because you're the guy giving
the presentation you're the guy who
proposing God you can't say I don't know
then when you know you come and give
your presentation well I'll allow you to
give your dissertation when you finish
your whole Theory your entire Theory and
tell us where where everything came from
if you cannot tell us that then thank
you come again next time okay see under
the Rope model very simple the thread
has always been there no one created the
Rope because you or the the thread the
single thread that underlies all matter
because you cannot convert space into
matter or matter into space
so the universe meaning all the matter
in the universe right was always there
will always be there after we're gone as
well but uh and it's just a little
thread that very thin thread that weaves
all matter and it's what in space in
other words we say in because I guess
there's no other word to use there it's
space that serves as backdrop what is
space nothing what is nothing the
opposite of something nothing that which
doesn't have shape a thing something is
that which has shape period we're done
but these people say well we don't know
how the instanton got there we don't
know how God got in there you know no
please tell us when when you're through
with a mechanism that converts nothing
into something please come and give you
a presentation that's who it is okay uh
so what is this thingy called The Ether
otherwise known as luminiferous ether
well it's in the Wikipedia we find this
definition okay or description right
ether was the postulated medium medium
thing object okay something for the
propagation of light there was something
there that allowed light to propagate
okay now the question is you know for
the propagation of light are we saying
that light propagates through something
else a different medium called The Ether
or is The Ether itself light the
vibration or whatever of The Ether
that's an important question to answer
it was invoked to explain the ability of
the Apparently wave-based light to
propagate through empty space a vacuum
right something that waves should not be
able to do okay uh the Assumption of a
space of a spatial planum space complete
filled with matter right or luminiferous
ether right space filled with matter
right that's what ether is rather than a
spatial vacuum provided the theoretical
medium that was required by way theories
of life in other words what there
they're saying in general uh terms is
that space is separate distinct from
ether ether is within space and for that
matter you know then you would have to
answer well what is space now you know
and they may space made of particles
which is exactly what the ether is
because ether is what occupies or is
within the walls of space it's what
fills space so to speak like if space
were a container that contains all the
particles known as ether okay so all
that's got to be clarified you got to
start there you got to show us what the
universe looks like you know space
matter ether whatever you want to put in
there uh false vacuum SpaceTime no
problem but you have to Define it you
have to tell us what we're seeing what
what our starting point is okay you
can't just start in the middle of the
road and say well you know what the
ether is you know what SpaceTime is you
know what the false vacuum is or what uh
virtual particles are coming in from the
vacuum no no we don't understand that
because if virtual particles come in
from the vacuum make themselves real you
know momentarily and then go back then
that means space is made out of
particles and if space is not made out
of particles and space contains these
particles that means you got to answer
what space is okay so and so on down the
line you got to clarify all that you
can't move beyond that and the Greeks
did their best but they didn't do very
good and no one has done any better
since than in mathematical physics the
are required the existence of an
invisible and infinite what material
with no interaction with physical
objects so we have a material that has
no ability to
touch intangible material okay do we
have that that's what what everybody
thought The Ether was and so when these
people say it's a fluid well they
haven't answered anything first you got
to spend 10 years on your ether on
defining what the ether is or pointing
to It Whatever spend 10 years developing
your ether then we'll listen to your
theory 5 seconds will
do but 10 years is what it takes for you
to really develop your ether not Theory
your ether hypothesis your assumption we
need your assumptions your suppositions
okay that's what we need okay and um
just so you can see what ether has been
through the ages okay here it is you
have all these fils from Greeks all the
way to really to the end of the 19th
century there and a little Beyond but
even people today talk about The Ether
very few relatively uh out of the
enthusiasts talk about The Ether but uh
this is what it's always been just a
bunch of dots lines you can say
segmented lines uh you know little dots
uh and they're flowing in a given
Direction okay that's what they show
there that's what's Illustrated that's
what's in front of my eyes okay and so
all these you could say particles
because I don't know how else to see
them they're all the arrows just shows
the direction in which they flow so they
have all this uh rain rain falling on
the Earth and the Sun and Etc okay I
don't know if it's all coming from one
side and that would be a important
question why why AR aren't these ether
particles coming from the other side of
the Sun for example right so you know
direction is important here you know
because it's easy to say well why do
things fall to the floor well because
the ether pushes them that's a problem
because the China man on the other side
of the earth his his spon falls in the
opposite direction to me you know and so
the also towards the center of the earth
that means the particles over there have
to be flowing in the opposite direction
okay so again the problem here is you
cannot explain ether for light or for
Gravity um you know you cannot explain
it with particles and that's what the
ether has always been bunch of particles
and that's why the ether really has died
but really it hasn't you know because
what is absolutely true you know is that
the false vacuum of the uh quantum
mechanics SpaceTime which is bunch of
events known as points right all these
are ether particles all e are ether
theories they're all ether
theories humans until today until we
came along have always talked about
particles discrete particles and you
cannot explain a single phenomenon inv
visible or intangible out there in the
universe with discreete particles that's
the whole problem so anyone who does
particles
meaning ether SpaceTime false vacuum
whatever you want to call it all those
people will never be able to answer the
questions of what is gravity what is
light what is electricity what is
magnetism Etc so you have to get rid of
the particle hypothesis the discrete
particle
hypothesis and as partly the reason
Quantum turned the particle the core
pusle you know the the real ball the the
you know that Newton had in mind
uh they got rid of that and today they
what do they accelerate quantities okay
they accelerate values numbers followed
by you know
units okay uh here are if you look up
the word ether you know on Google um
images this what you'll find okay see
you can see there everybody thinks of
The Ether in the same way and that's
what they use to prop up their theories
okay this is this is the assumption that
it's a bunch of particles flowing in a
given Direction so when I tell these
ethers that come here that um ether is
just a bunch of particles oh bill you
don't know what ether is you're wrong
blah blah blah okay I'm wrong no problem
I I'll accept it tell me you tell me
what the ether is and they can't they
say well it's a fluid that
flows okay so here's the
ether everybody wanted to know what the
ether looks like
here it is okay I'll show it to you for
the first time in your life that's what
the ether is bunch of particles they
vibrate and the vibration makes those
waves that's what it's always been
that's what always people people had
always in mind when they talked about
The Ether especially in the 19th century
when they said waves you know uh Thomas
Young suggested or really it was
suggested since the days of hin and uh
and Robert Hook that uh light was a
bunch of waves right but Thomas Young
showed through the slid experiment at
least that apparently light had some
kind of wave nature then frell and uh
others you know later on Faraday and uh
Maxwell uh they got into the wave nature
of light and they were always thinking
of this they were thinking of ether
vibrating and when Michael S and morning
came around in the 80s there 1887 I
think it was well they got rid of The
Ether they said we can't detect any
difference in uh in light you know when
they split light they couldn't detect
the the difference in speed of light in
One Direction or the other when the
earth just went around the Sun and so
that's when they concluded hey there
can't be any ether especially not an
ether like if you think of a Sandbox
nothing moving just sand there just
sitting there that's one possibility the
other one is the grains are flowing so
either they flow or they stand still and
either way you cannot explain anything
in you cannot explain light specifically
light that's the one we want to explain
and you cannot explain it with ether and
so the vibration of these particles or
the standing still of the particles it
doesn't matter anyway one way or the
other it's all garbage ether is garbage
and has always been garbage to this day
and quantum mechanics relies on The
Ether still it's a particle hypothesis
and that's what that's that's what they
show that there's a bunch of particles
there filling up space they come into
the real world as virtual particles and
go back to form part of what The Ether
and uh yeah like this Nobel
Prize uh said he says uh the vacuum the
quantum vacuum the one they use every
day in mathematical physics is an ether
but they don't call it that because it's
kaboo Robert
Laughin
okay so uh here's a flowchart for all
those ether ISS who want to
challenge uh what I just said and this
what this is what we're going to ask you
so I'm putting I'm putting the cards on
the table you can't accuse me says this
this says Bill you're going to trash
whatever I put in there it doesn't
matter that's my job just like your job
is to trash me my job is to trash you
that's what it the scientific discussion
is all about you know if you can't
defend your posture well it's it's not
that you lost there's no losing or
winning in science it's just that you
you can't defend your posture you know
so so you have no case you're the guy
who is supposed to present your case to
the jury the jury are your peers there
you know where they're listening to you
and they say okay what is this guy
saying what is your ether what what are
you proposing so you have to tell them
and this is what you we're going to ask
you I'm going to put it on L on the
table for you to to look at this is The
Ether flowchart okay what I call The
Ether flowchart uh is he either infinite
or finite you need to answer that
question okay no matter what is it
malleable or rigid I mean you can make
it of a single piece or segmented it
doesn't matter but if it's a single
piece you can say it's malleable or you
can say it's rigid you can say you do
one no problem but you have to defend
these ideas these
proposals and uh is it equal to space or
is it contained within space I mean are
ether and space
synonyms right or is one contained
within the other meaning really The
Ether within space okay and in that case
you got to tell us what space is like is
it container does it have you know does
it stop somewhere in which case you got
to tell me what
continues what encapsulates space you
know draw it that's the question draw it
okay okay so here uh one fellow U out
there uh you know because a lot of these
ethers say what it's a fluid that flows
flu flow flow flu okay great okay so
it's a flu flow and here here you can
see the type of problems that these
people have in making their
presentations their dissertation instead
of going out there and telling us
spending two hours on their hypothesis
and saying look this is what a fluid is
right they start in the middle of the of
the uh show The Middle of the uh movie
and they start telling you what the
fluid does
and things about the fluid but they
never they never start at fluid what is
a fluid and you can see here how they
make their presentations let me show you
this and this is more or less how ether
is in general talk and wh why it's it's
irrational because they skip over the
important steps we never get a handle on
what they're talking about when they're
already talking about the motion what it
does okay here it is to get all this
fluid dynamics going we start at the
subatomic level that underlies molecular
interactions we average out the
molecules by establishing the fluid as a
continuous
field this Continuum is then discretized
spatially and temporarily whatever that
will
mean oh great presentation whatever that
will mean I mean this is how the guy
presented his case in prominent site
okay so yeah they say it's a field like
if you knew what a field is what is it a
football field or poppy field you know
what is it and then you know they just
begin talking about the fluid and that's
more or less what all these people do
they listen to stuff like this and then
they just say I'm going to say the same
thing about The Ether it's a fluid and
let me tell you what it does no no I
haven't I haven't yet understood what
the fluid what what your ether is I mean
even in this case you can see they're
talking about a fluid what is a fluid
made of molecules which are made of
atoms right so is your ether made of
atoms made of molecules and more than
likely guys going to say no of course
not okay then you got to you got to tell
me a lot more about the ether before you
continue because if you're going to talk
about a fluid I'm going to say oh so
you're saying that are made out of
molecules and and atoms if you say no
then you haven't started in the you know
on the right
foot you you ski some important step
there there okay so that's what's what
the point is here okay and yeah and so
the issue for this fell who talked about
the fluid right is here you can see it
we want to know what the black stuff is
that gives shape or contrast or Contour
to each one of his molecules he started
talking about the molecules the visible
stuff and he forgot about the invisible
stuff or the black stuff there that
serves as contrast that's what we want
to identify you know is he talking about
are these
particles or whatever these molecules in
water are they in air are they out there
in space you know uh you got to identify
the medium first before you can continue
you got to tell me everything that I see
in that field of view and so this fellow
just jumped directly into fluids he said
let me tell you all I know about the
fluid I'm an expert in fluids yeah you
might be an expert in fluid but you know
nothing about backgrounds first we need
the or about science for that matter you
need to identify the background I need
to see an object and a background when
you put a background I need to ask you
the question you know what is that stuff
behind it you can't avoid that and you
can say well I don't know no no you're
giving the present there you can't tell
me I don't know you put it there in
front of me you got to tell me what it
is you can't say that part I don't know
let me tell you the visible
stuff that's the way they all these
people talk that's how they give their
presentations okay so uh more or less
here f that same question essentially in
my face okay which is correct no problem
okay he says so according to you the
universe is
finite absolutely not there's no such
thing as universe universe is a concept
only objects can be finite okay so
what's Universe Universe the definition
matter and space two things there really
thing and a nothing okay so we have a
thing and a nothing we have two we treat
the nothing as a thing for for the
purposes of identifying the word
universe and so we're saying there's two
things there or two concepts okay and so
universe is a concept you can't say the
universe is this the universe is Big
it's small it's infinite because the
universe is a concept you either talk
about matter and you say that matter is
either finite or countable you know if
you're going to talk about atoms you
know you're can to say there's a fixed
number of at in the universe no more and
no less okay and then you have can talk
about space and tell us what space is in
in our uh here in in rational science
space is that which doesn't have shape
that's what space is that's a synonym of
nothing a vacuum okay and um yeah the
single thread is an object there you see
it that's what we propose and as you can
see it's finite okay because it's a
closed loop thread okay and it underlies
all matter it's it's always been there
it will always be there when we're gone
so he says oh what's okay what's it into
what's outside the wall and again there
is no outside the wall the you can say
the outside the wall I guess he's
talking about the thread uh is the black
stuff and the black stuff is not a stuff
it's nothing it's the opposite of stuff
it's that which doesn't have shape
that's what the black stuff is I put a
square around it only so that to limit
it but you have to assume that this
black stuff has no borders no edges no
surface okay because it's that which
doesn't have shape that's why we can't
draw space okay and the thread is within
space and it makes up every single atom
every single rope that interconnects
every atom in the universe and this more
or less the flow of thought we have the
single closed loop thread okay you have
to think of it as a think of it as a
rubber band but that doesn't stretch
remember the thread does not stretch and
people sometimes say ask that question
no it's made out of a single piece it's
malleable and it's closed loop and it
doesn't stretch okay I don't know what
other thing you want to know about it
but just ask it's very thin how thin is
it in physics we say it's very thin
that's as accurate as it gets okay we
don't care about numbers in physics we
don't care how big it is we don't care
how small it is we don't okay how thin
it is it's very thin and it's very long
if we were to undo every atom in the
universe and that's what we use we use
the the adjective
very okay
or adverb in this case Okay twine it
twines and turns into this uh ropeik
entity right so that's what's going to
make every rope that connects every atom
that connects every rope that connects
every atom in the unit universe so we
have atom rope atom rope atom rope all
through the universe and you can see
there that every atom in the universe is
interconnected we're connected to the
same to an atom at the opposite side of
the universe okay that's why um the
Andromeda galaxy is being pulled towards
Earth and Earth is being pulled towards
the Andromeda galaxy because every atom
in the Andromeda galaxy is bound to
every atom on Earth including every atom
in your body okay so that's the
Assumption called supposition assumption
hypothesis okay so that's that's what we
propose and so with that now we can
explain you know what light is the
torsion of the rope that you can see up
there the 2D 3D uh rope that into
connects two atoms the atoms pump expand
and contract known as Quantum jump and
when they do they torque the rope and
the torsion of the Rope is light and the
reason we have gravity is that all these
ropes
uh they don't tug okay they don't tug
but as two objects approach each other
uh the ropes fan out and so you have
acceleration of gravity that's that's uh
light and gravity and a nutshell there
for you okay okay so that's the model
okay so I don't know what the issue is
and here just in case we have a little
evidence for those of you who want proof
evidence you know ETA Authority
tradition democracy all the people who
voted for the theory uh a lot of people
are into that in science we don't pay
any attention to that opinions have
nothing to do with anything in science
okay but here we have um evidence proof
for those who want it you know here's uh
Richard Muller he's at UC Berkeley and
he says so for example here if you have
the Earth there's a big Mass here and
you have you with your little Mass here
he drew it there on the board you can
see it every atom on Earth is pulling on
every atom of you you're also pulling on
it
simple straightforward how do you pull
on an atom on Earth how does one of your
atoms pull on an atom of Earth and how
does one atom of Earth pull on you
unless there is some elongated entity
that interconnects us intangible
invisible elongated entity that connects
the two atoms if you can tell me that
hey maybe maybe you're going to win an
noal prize there is no way of explaining
that except that there is some invisible
intang entity that connects every
atom okay and we made a pair of twine
threads because we have torsion and
torsion is what light is it's always
been confused with this up and down
transverse wave or standing wave or
whatever
okay okay um and what's been the problem
well the problem all these years all
these centuries has been that people
have never been able to see or touch the
mediators okay but you're supposed to to
make an assumption like you know they
talk about entanglement what is
entanglement one particle affects
another and there's no mediator
entanglement means equal right or colon
right followed by no mediator that's
what entanglement means okay so every
time you hear entanglement means no
medior epr you einowski
Rosen uh no mediator that's what it
means so whenever they mention these
fantastic scientific words they mean no
mediator action at a distance which is
the scientific term for black magic and
Witchcraft okay that's what it is okay
so we have two things you know two
objects two particles
whatever and uh the question is you know
there's something happening in there
that you can measure but you can't see
the mediator okay so this one does
something and affects this one you know
either instantaneously or after a while
it doesn't really matter this one
affects that one but there's no mediator
you cannot see it or touch it there's
nothing there okay so you make an
assumption okay you make an assumption
and whatever assumption you make you
know these people the mathematics what
they do they put an equation to describe
that they describe what they think
happened in there okay and so let's say
this one affects this one somehow again
through time instantaneously any way you
want it doesn't matter this one affects
that one you can't see or touch what in
between and so they put one in there
something in there okay they they
forcefully put something in there with
their imagination they say well I think
it's a bunch of invisible rabbits
they're jumping up and down right maybe
you found the wave nature of what's
happening in there you say I think it's
a bunch of rabbits that are just jumping
up and down invisible intangible rabbits
right that are going from point A to
point B and that's how a affects B okay
we can't see them it's action at a
distance but really it's not really
action at a distance there is something
there we're going to say it's bunch of
rabbits that are jumping so this is what
you visualize let mean Illustrated for
you here this is what you visualize okay
you see rabbits going from from left to
right okay on your screen and say okay
and so now you go out there and you do
your equations you measure and you come
up with an equation you win your nobble
prize you go on the talk circuit right
because you you discovered what was in
there it was a bunch of rabbits that are
jumping okay
it turns out that you know Mother Nature
put something else something different
in there that you didn't even think
about and it's this so worm that's
torquing so what you thought with
jumping rabbits was a torquing
worm okay and it's a little different
you know the equations that you would
need for that would be different so you
went out there and did all this work
okay on jumping rabbits you you had all
these discret rabbits and you put them
in your equation you describe them
perfectly well but it turns out mother
nature doesn't have jumping rabbits
Mother Nature had you know a torquing
worm and so the question is you know the
top one the same thing as the bottom one
there you know I mean if you make
equations for the top one turns out that
Mother Nature has something different
has the bottom one uh have you wasted
your time uh what is it 400 years of
mathematical physics describing that
which Ain
which are the rabbits out there the
discreet stuff and not the elongated
continuous worm that's at the bottom
that doesn't move anywhere just torqus
in place so it is important to identify
you know the mediator before you do any
mathematics otherwise you're wasting
your time and all these people are
talking about particles and particles
and particles The Ether the electric
universes Everybody Talks mainstream
they all talk about particles they all
want to simulate everything with
particles the atom two particles you
know a proton and an electron dundeal
then you say is that your atom well not
really we don't know what the atom looks
like but that's how they simulate it and
that's the one they're going to use for
ionization
electricity uh Quantum jump they do it
all with this atom you know the quantum
jump the electron jumps back and forth
you know around the the proton
ionization the electron leaves are
leaves or another one comes in there so
they all do it with a planetary model
and when you say is that your atom is is
the planetary model your atom well not
really we don't know what the atom looks
like so you need to know what your atom
looks like before you do go out there
and do all this stuff saying electricity
is the flow of electron bees from atom
to atom you cannot say that until you
tell me what your atom looks like
otherwise you're doing all this thinking
all this measurement all these equations
and you don't know what what you're
measuring what are you measuring you are
you measuring rabbits jumping rabbits or
are you measuring you a torquing
worm you need to determine that before
you do a lot of math and that's the
problem with the ether they they they
start telling you about the fluids but
they don't tell you what the fluid what
this fluid is they don't draw it for
they don't illustrate for you okay and
if you want to illustrate you got to see
the whole thing like I want to ask you
what is a table I don't know what a
table is you know here's the cling on he
ask what is a table and you point to a
table you don't have to be the best
artist in the world you can get a sketch
of a table you can get somebody else's
picture and say this is a table and you
point to it and now he knows what a
table is is a table made out of atoms
yeah is it made out of molecules of
course you know a table is made out of
all these same but we don't say well a
table is what it's made out of because
then an elephant is what it's made out
of a rock is what it's made out tree is
what it's made out of are we going to
count the number of atoms say a tree has
5 billion atoms and a table or a house
has you know six billion is that the way
we Define table is that the way we
Define house no we point and say that's
a house that's a table that's a tree
that's a rock and that's what we want to
do with the ether point to something
that has shape and then you can do
whatever you want with it but that's the
starting point you can't do that you got
nothing you got to work a lot more on
your
hypothesis okay so let's move on to the
subject matter of today and that's
gravitational lensing what the hell is
gravitational lensing I'm wondering well
it's the bending of light essentially
that's what it is but let's go with the
you know formal definition because we're
not I'm not going to put words in their
mouth I want them to put words in my
mouth here right okay let them let it
hear it from the horse's mouth okay here
it is and here's the European uh space
agency and NASA this is what they have
for gravitational lensing it goes more
or less like this gravitational lensing
occurs when a occurs right it's An
Occurrence it's an event phenomena uh
when a massive Celestial body such as a
Galaxy cluster causes a sufficient
curvature of SpaceTime for the path of
light around it to be visibly bent as if
by a lens the body causing the light to
curve is accordingly called what
gravitational lens okay and I want you
to I want to focus on that word path
okay uh because this is going to be the
the key word here throughout the lecture
today path can be an object you know
like a dirt road or a trail or a road
whatever a highway or it can be a verb
you know the itinerary the
trajectory and mathematical physics
likes to confound words you know they
like to mix them and say it's a verb
object it's an object verb in other
words they use the word path in both
ways in the same sentence and that's
what I want you to focus on as I go
through the lecture today okay keep in
mind the word path okay that's going to
be the tricky one it says according to
Einstein's general theory of relativity
time and space are fused together in a
quantity known as space time within this
Theory mass of objects called SpaceTime
to curve and gravity is simply the
curvature of SpaceTime as light travels
through SpaceTime the theory predicts oh
it's going to do some predictions here
huh that the path okay taken by light
will also be curved what are we talking
about path curved well looks like uh are
you talking about a road or are they
talking about an itinerary what's being
curved by an object's Mass they're going
to curve the path okay gravitational
lensing is a dramatic and observable
example of Einstein's theory in Action
Extreme massive celestial bodies such as
Galaxy clusters cause SpaceTime to be
significantly curved and that's
interesting because space time is a
concept it's four uh number lines which
they call coordinates or Dimensions
depending on the day of the week and
they say these uh number lines are
curved that's great so how do you curve
a number line is a number line a thing
that you can curve like a banana or a
hammock u in other words they act as a
gravit as gravitational lenses when
light from a distant light source passes
by a gravitational lens the path of the
light again the path of the light is
curved are we talking about an itinerary
slash trajectory you know uh motion or
are we talking about a road Trail
highway what are we talking about here
what do you mean the path is curved and
a distorted image of the distant object
maybe a ring or a Halo of light around
the gravitational lens can can be
observed okay so that's uh internatal
the definition or the notion of what a
gravitational lensing is it's a
phenomenon okay that they observe the
astronomer see out there little light
around Halo so to speak uh Galaxy behind
a Galaxy a star behind a star that sort
of thing okay and uh here we have
um an illustration okay and let me turn
this on I think this from the
Wikipedia so uh just watch there's no
sound here but you can see what they're
referring to when they talk about
gravitational lensing it's just an
illustration of how light from a Galaxy
from behind shines around a Galaxy
that's in front of it and so they say
what's happening light is curved by the
mass of the Galaxy that is between your
eye and the far away Galaxy so here it
is just an illustration a little dip
here
you can see the background and a
foreground Galaxy there and you can see
what happens to light you're going to
curve it okay to your eye to the
detectors here on Earth okay and that's
essentially what it
is okay so it's just the curving of
light okay it's just the curving of
light around the Galaxy very simple
concept I don't think you need to know
much more than that about you know this
gravitational lensing you have something
behind another you have an eclipse right
you have a Umbra penumbra whichever uh
one behind another and you can see this
thing the Halo at least through a Galaxy
that's in front of it that is eclipsing
it why because they say like
curves okay that's the explanation
that's the physical interpretation for
why we see that okay so they're
explaining a phenomena they're giving
you a physical interpretation they later
on when you put them against the wall
they say oh we don't give physical
interpretations that's not part of our
job descriptions mathematical physics
and so they dismiss all that stuff well
do you or don't you well they do because
otherwise their equations are worthless
so they have to turn it into some kind
of physical interpretation some kind of
explanation some kind of mechanism cause
okay they have to give you that because
otherwise their equations are worthless
just that
simple okay so here we have it uh all
everybody knows his name is Matt odow he
works for people at
PBS okay and he uh gives you an idea of
uh you know what this uh gravitational
lensing is all about listen to him
carefully okay I'm going to uh just
mouth the words that he said so I'm not
putting words in his mouth in a way but
it's it's what he said I just said it
with my mouth okay here it
goes in the real Universe both space and
time can be
curved the curvature produced by Mass
Gives
Gravity the path traveled by light
follows the
curve and so gravity bends the path of
light
good old m d he is a caricature of a
scientist uh I mean he's not a real
scientist he just parrots what the
establishment you know fed him that's
what it is and so what can I say these
are the people who talk on the internet
there's tons of them there's only little
old me against all of them so there's
tons of them and of course they're going
to give you the party line that's all
but they cannot explain a single
phenomenon and they admit that they
cannot explain a single phenomenon or as
uh Richard fan said in the 60s he
said what is it uh physicist or
mathematical physics has given up on
that they don't give physical
interpretation they give you an
irrational one when you call their Bluff
they say well we don't do that anyway
it's not part of our job description
it's not our line of work so why did you
give me a physical interpretation if
it's not in your line of work if it's
not part of your job your job
description your everyday duties okay
why did you give me this
BS
interpretation you know and I'll tell
you what they he he they don't they
don't give you a physical interpretation
the equations are worthless that's why
and again they could be doing equations
for jumping rabbits and you know maybe
uh what they're looking at is a torquing
snake you know
so that's another thing well anyways uh
good old Matt he uh mentions
one of the first guys to prove you know
um that Einstein was right regarding
this uh what is it the light bending
okay and this is the picture that is so
famous out there 1919 there you see the
one of the articles that came out in
those days okay it says lights all a
skew in the heavens men of science more
or less a Gog over results of eclipse
observations okay Einstein the triumphs
that's when Einstein became a big man he
got his Nobel Prize two years later okay
because well partly because of this
right uh he got it for the um
photoelectric effect of 1905 that he uh
uh mathematized you can say and uh but
he was also given it because of this
because his prediction came true and
people were changing their minds about
how the universe works okay so uh says
there stars not where they seem to be
okay yeah and uh but nobody need worry
yeah okay so anyways the point here is
that you can see the halo around the the
eclipse of the Sun and that Halo is a
star behind the sun okay and so they
said hey you know Einstein was right
light does curve around okay around the
sun when there's an eclipse you can see
it there you can see the glare of a star
that's behind the sun okay so uh this is
what they showed okay that light curves
around in fact the Sun's light curves
around the Moon there you can see it
there as well so I guess we're we're all
you know in agreement light seems to
curve around the sun right and
so keep in mind two words you know one
was path okay and the other question you
need to or you need to compare is curved
we can put warp there we can put bent
there as well versus
deflected does light curve or is light
deflected okay keep that in mind we're
going to get back to that okay okay so
here's my illustration of what uh Mr
Edington had in mind okay there's some
kind of
wall okay maybe it's not on the outside
but it is in a way because what they're
saying is that uh the sun weighs down
SpaceTime creating those walls in
SpaceTime and the little Photon or the
wave whichever uh has no other choice
but to slide around or drift or roll
around those curved walls made by the
Sun so you don't have to think of this
as gravity pulling towards the center of
the sun you have which is what Newton
suggested you have to think of this as
the sun weighing down SpaceTime warping
the
walls uh through which the photon has to
slide so the walls are on the outside
okay not on the inside very important
and this is essentially what they what
Einstein proposed and this is the what
we have even to this day that this is
the explanation for why light curves the
sunways um SpaceTime downwards and the
photon has no other choice but to slide
around in a curved space SLS SpaceTime
okay essentially they're warping time
whatever that
means they're warping time okay okay so
here we have because of this these ideas
you have the first one here we call them
idiots what's an idiot idiots a person
with Big Ideas okay so we call them
ideats because they don't have little
ideas idea we call them idiots okay
here's uh one of the conclusion from
these idiots um and this comes out of
the Wikipedia it says that point
particles can also curve SpaceTime I
guess they should if they Point
particles and they have I guess mass
that means every particle in the
universe keep this in mind okay every
particle in the universe is waiting down
SpaceTime somewhere so SpaceTime is not
a smooth thing as they always show you
you know this canvas it's full of
potholes and I mean not just one here
and one there I mean all of SpaceTime is
just practically covered with pothole
because every little thing weighs
SpaceTime downwards I guess downwards
whatever downwards is out there you know
okay so everything every little atom in
the universe is weighing down SpaceTime
that's the the uh proposal by Channel
relativity by Mr Einstein okay so
they're saying it all weighs everything
down okay and so yeah the point like a
particle right assuming it's got some
Mass I guess weighs down space time that
means light Never Should travel straight
you know re linearly it has to go
through all these little Pooles every
step it takes you wonder how plural
light does this I mean not even God
designed such a monstrous world you know
this is just out of beyond our
imagination but that's what they say a
point particle what is it lack spatial
extension okay so there's nothing there
it weighs something that nothing weighs
something meaning it weighs down
SpaceTime and by doing so it
deflects the path of
light every step light takes it's
deflected you try to explain that okay
so light never travels in a straight
line in general relativity it can't
because all masses weigh down SpaceTime
every
atom okay so um here we have another
group of idiots
uh Big Ideas right here it is and they
say that because of this right uh do you
know does light travel straight or Cur
well let Al light even the the Earth
they say in 4D the Earth orbits around
the Sun in a straight
line in a straight line in 4D space the
projection of a straight line onto a 3D
Volume is still a straight line but it
may have some oscillation due to the
presence of a for spatial Dimension so
there you have the rational orbit that
normal people even people in the ancient
days knew about you know they they were
aware that the earth goes around the Sun
and each people say no no you're wrong
Bill uh our
relativity uh gurus tell us something
different that the Earth and the Moon
travel straight and I guess they they go
outside the solar system I mean I don't
know I don't know what they mean by
Straight okay but they say that in for
the they travel straight and since
everybody says that we do live or exist
in a 4D SpaceTime here I guess the one
on the left is out of bounds you know
it's wrong you the Moon and the Earth
travel straight now you know it you
heard it here
first okay so we have all these people
you know they have all these irrational
conclusion all these irrational
explanations physical interpretations
mechanism causes they have all are
irrational the words coming out of their
mouths are all irrational okay the way
they express themselves maybe they just
need to better their language no problem
but then work on the language don't
don't tell me that the Earth travels
straight in 4D SpaceTime butting curves
here on Earth what the hell does that
mean what can it possibly
mean okay and the same with light
light Earth doesn't matter okay um
gravitational lensing is essentially a
the same experiment or observation out
there in space space has the experiment
here on Earth known as a slid experiment
you know here you have uh straight light
and it curves around the sun because uh
SpaceTime is Warped by the presence of
the sun right and so uh yeah you get
this uh curvature of light according to
general relativity and that's more or
less what happens in the quantum world
with a slit experiment you know the
light goes straight but somehow on the
other side of the uh
slits uh
you have all these waves they curve
around they begin to interfere with each
other so you go from straight light to
curved light so all these people see in
curves they say everything is curves and
uh you know uh we do have an explanation
for the slid experiment which more or
less has a little to do it's going to be
the same mechanism we proposed for
gravitational lensing so here's the
illustration of our mechanism M of how
um the Rope explains this and what it is
is that you know you have essentially a
light source and all the ropes are
connected already to everything else and
so if you put not a pair of slits you
put you know uh some kind of needle you
know something like that okay you put
something like that in front of it and
the question is you know uh if if you
have photons
particles they should go straight out
they should they have nothing to bounce
against and come back in and that's the
way uh mathematicians illustrate the uh
uh slit experiment it hits the you know
the walls of the slit and then bounce
inwards but if you have no walls of
slits if you only have something in the
center you know how do you produce the
coming back in of that whole beam what's
it bouncing against why does it come
back in okay and in this case why does
it produce these waves these transfer or
transverse or whichever waves they want
I mean it doesn't matter they can
produce longitudinal transverse waves
doesn't matter but how does it come in
why don't they just continue going
straight if there's nothing to bounce
against to come in back in there's no
sill no window sill in other words right
where to bounce against okay and so
here's my needle experiment and what I
did was I put a laser pointer you can do
this at home very cheap experiment not a
billion dollar experiment you put a
laser pointer and you put farther down a
few meters down the road you put a chair
with your uh Cork and a needle stuck to
the cork okay and you're going to shine
the laser pointer exactly at the needle
you got to you know position it there so
that it hits the needle and on the four
four wall you will see uh fringes which
is what Thomas young saw for the first
time in fact apparently Newton was the
first one to carry out that experiment
according to Thomas Young he says that
in his book okay but here it is uh I
carried out this experiment some years
back uh I think it's still valid so here
it goes watch it
carefully here you can see the laser
pointer okay and then another chair I
put a uh needle stuck to a cork okay and
then farther down the road you can see
some light out there so I'm going to go
to that light now okay you can see what
the light does what what it is all
static so nothing's moving and you can
see the Fring is there
okay okay very straightforward you can
do this at home prove it to yourself
okay H you don't have to believe my word
okay so the question is you can produce
fringes with a needle you don't need
slits you don't need two slits and then
if you don't have the slits you don't
have anything for light to bounce
against and come back in if uh you know
if you need the bouncing without the
slits without the windows Sills right
the the frames it'll just go straight it
should go straight there's no reason for
it to come back in but it does but as
you can see with a needle it curves
around the needle and so uh that's like
the case of gravitational lensing are we
saying that the needle is weighing down
SpaceTime and that's why it
curves light around with you know needle
how much does it weigh one
gram and it curves light around because
of all that weight or like the other guy
said there uh Point particle also weighs
down SpaceTime it bends space time
that's why light curves inwards because
you're bending SpaceTime around the
needle you see the
issue okay those are questions for you
to ponder okay so what's the big problem
well why do we have this uh problem with
uh gravitational lensing and the slit
experiment and all these other good
things entanglement you can also include
in there Etc um language you know what
it's called word salad semantics what
these people dismiss is oh you're doing
a semantic argument bill yeah we're
doing a semantic argument now the guys
doing semantic are the other people not
me I'm trying to Define my words I'm
accused of doing semantics no it's the
people who use the words wrong who are
doing semantics word Sal and word
Wizardry okay so here it is this is the
problem what is a mathematical physicist
an individual who doesn't understand the
difference between an adverb and an
adjective okay here are the verbs common
verbs that mathematicians mathemagicians
sorry typically confused for nouns
itinerary it's not a noun not in physics
orbit orbital motion trajectory uh path
energy charge number Mass force field
time none of of these are nouns in
physics in physics it's got to be an
object to be a noun okay that's the only
one that can serve as the subject of a
sentence those are the only nouns
allowed in physics okay it's not the
orbit of Jupiter it's Jupiter orbits
orbits is what it does and then you have
ether wave plasma electricity
Singularity you know what is a
singularity SpaceTime black hole Dark
Matter function conscience and tesser
act these are just some of the words I
could go on with uh more these just came
out of the top of my head okay what's an
adjective a qualifier or modifier of a
noun or of an object in physics here we
talking about an adjective for the
purposes of physics okay we're saying
that what qualifies a physical object
that's what we're talking about it's
what is right not what it does and there
you see straight curved bent finite
infinite continuous bound flat work
perpect perpendicular segmented inner
exist 2D and 3D you know if something is
threedimensional
that's adjective of an object on the
other hand uh we have adverbs those are
qualifiers of verbs motions and Concepts
primarily concept we say but we put
those in there so that you know what
we're talking about uh it's it's about
what it's doing not what it is but what
it's doing and it refers to motion
primarily and there you can see some of
the adverbs which are treated is
adjectives or who knows what or
sometimes not used at all deflected
diverted SS incessant ceaseless
Perpetual constant curvilinear
rectilinear Dead Alive living being in
4D four dimensional what is that means
time time had better involved motion and
hopefully a 4D entity is something
already in motion you cannot say well I
cannot imagine A four-dimensional
Spacetime like Mr Hawkings said no you
of course he cannot because he's talking
about motion he's talking about a
concept he's talking about a dynamic
concept and he's trying to imagine a
physical object so this is where we
start we start with language we have a
problem with the language that these
people use today and we're going to see
some of the problems that these uh
confusions that these people have um or
misinterpretations uh what they they
cause in physics okay they cause
enormous problems in communication and
it's them who are doing word salad
because they're treating all these words
in an irrational manner okay not wrong
it's irrational okay okay so um what is
light here we have it okay we have a
straight transverse electromagnetic wave
that's what we thought a wave was at
least all the way till Maxwell right and
now we're starting to curve light around
you know I don't know how many beers
these guys drink but they curve light
around okay they say curves around the
Sun so are they warping the wave I mean
don't we need to know if it's a wave or
a particle for that matter right here's
a wave and and you're bending it you're
you're warping it you're you know you're
uh you're turning it around you're
you're curving it okay and so the
question here is uh are we going to say
that a wave is curved or that it is
deflected are we talking about something
in motion which is taken out out of its
itinerary I won't use the word path
because it's very confusing are we
taking it out of its trajectory is that
what it is which means it's deflected or
are we talking about a physical object
that is curved like a banana like a
hammock or whatever are we talking about
a continuous object here for the wave is
that what a wave is okay does a wave of
light stretch from here to androma
uninterruptedly or does it flow like a
little boat from Andromeda down here you
know
little wave that moves little by little
you know all the way down here so we
need to establish that are we talking is
the wave is the wave interrupted at some
point is there a beginning to the wave
an end to the wave you know outside the
atoms I mean because if if it has a
beginning in an atom over there and it
stretches
[Music]
or extends uninterruptedly all the way
to my eye then yeah the the way
connects my eye to that atom okay do we
understand that okay otherwise it
travels like a little boat like a
sailboat you know a little wave just
emitted and CH yeah good riddens you
know you're out so you got to determine
whether the wave is continuous all the
way to Andromeda galaxy extending all
the way down there or if it travels the
wave you know they always give you a
piece of a wave you know several
links I'd like to know if the wave
stretches uninterruptedly from
andrometer to my eye okay and this is
the other version this is the particle
version okay straight line again uh they
really are referring to Rector linear
travel um not a straight line but they
turn these um verbs and adverbs into
adjectives and nouns that's the problem
okay I mean we talking about straight
line or rectal linear uh trajectory
Rector linear itinerary what are we
talking about H you know are we talking
about all these particles moving is that
what it is or are we talking about a
straight line see that's not a line
that's a bunch of dots and if each one
is location one of the two either uh
there's one dot that is occupying all
those locations or there are all those
dots occupying each one its own location
and I guess they all move forward or
something you know so you got to
determine what you mean by straight line
of photon which is what the term they
use and then you have the bent line
which is a curv linear or curved line
they call it right or warped line so um
again you know are we talking about a
line or are we talking about a whole
bunch of apples okay if a whole bunch of
apples uh you got also to explain you
know why what causes it to bend like
that to warp like that and they say well
because SpaceTime is bent or warped by
the Sun and then the photon has no
alternative but to slide or Roll Along
warp SpaceTime that's the explanation we
receive okay if that's the case then
SpaceTime has to be a physical object
you cannot later say well we don't know
what SpaceTime is or SpaceTime is not an
object as mathematical concept because
you're warping a thing to give me a
physical
interpretation so you cannot later deny
what you just said okay otherwise these
people live in contradiction or they
give you the what they always say well
we don't do that philosophy that's
interpretation we don't do that we do
equations if you do equations stick to
equations don't try to Bluff don't try
to your way you know don't try to
convince me that you understand how this
universe works that SpaceTime is Warped
and you've proven it with so many
experiments no you got to make sense of
that if you can't make sense of it then
don't give me any physical
interpretations just stick to your
equations and stick them up your nose
holes also you know because they have no
importance in physics in physics we
don't use equations in physics we have
to explain the mechanism okay that's
what people want to know people want to
know why this spoon you know falls to
the floor that's all you need to explain
please tell me what causes that to go to
the floor and not to the ceiling then
we're done but don't tell me that
SpaceTime is warp and SpaceTime is you
treat it like physical object then and
say well we don't understand it anywayss
it's not part of physics anyways then
then why did you do that why did you try
to convince me that SpaceTime is
work because otherwise your equations
are worthless that's why okay so here we
have Mr OD doubt again put him up there
so again so he says and so gravity bends
the path of light and the path traveled
by light follows the curve okay so he
concludes that yeah gravity bends light
okay but again uh you got to explain it
he's just describing that and that's his
interpretation that's his opinion but he
has no justification for what he's
saying right so yeah he's a caricature
of a scientist he's not a scientist
scientist someone who can tell you why
okay and if he's goingon to say that
this is caused by War SpaceTime because
that sun weighs you know SpaceTime
downwards then he's treating SpaceTime
as a physical objects he cannot later
deny and say well I was just only
kidding I was giving you an ology and
you're not supposed to take it literally
and all that good stuff that
mathematicians you all the arguments
they created over the years because
that's what they do they give you one to
show you that they know and that you
don't they're going to educate you and
then you say yeah but SpaceTime is a
physical object well you weren't
supposed to take it literally it's not a
trampoline it's not a canvas for for
real it's the way we explain our
mathematics bring it down to your
peasant level
the question is who's who's the peasant
here you know is it the listener or the
guy giv the dissertation okay and then
here we have our conclusions we can say
here it is questions ask a mathematician
okay these are conclusions is light a
flow of particles you know or is it uh
you know uh strung out waves you know
they extend forever the waves or do the
waves travel as a little sailboat
meaning they're discrete waves meaning
it's a wave packet you know what is a
wave does wave get broken at some point
is it cut off from other
waves that's one of the question you
need to answer and then you need to know
what a particle is is it a value is it a
magnitude an amount is it a number
followed by a unit is that what a
particle is or is it a corus is a
ball we're going to talk about balls you
know or we going to talk about you know
values mathema ICS okay that's important
are we talking physics or we talking
math okay and they never do that they
want to put both of them together call
it math F mathematical physics right and
again is light a wave or is it a but if
you look at the wave it's a bunch of
vectors you know magnitude and Direction
that's a number so is a wave just a
bunch of numbers a magnitude a direction
what is this what is a wave okay is a
description mathematical description of
something
and they represent it with this you know
uh vectors and they move the vectors
around they they show you this wave in
front of you you say okay I understand
it's a physical object right because I
see something in front of me that's got
shape it's moving no no it's you're
staring at is a mathematical concept
that they're moving bunch of vectors
okay magnitude and Direction
perpendicular to each other you know how
does how do numbers go perpendicular to
each other how do numbers have Direction
how do numbers
flow okay so we need to establish what
uh light is is there a wave is there a
particle what do you mean by particle
what do you mean by wave that has to be
upfront if you can't begin that you
cannot enter physics you cannot begin
your dissertation in physics these
people jump in the middle of the show
and say well you know what a wave is you
know it's that thing that's moving there
on the screen no no I don't understand
what I'm looking I'm looking at a bunch
of vectors that are moving numbers that
are moving w w w how much did you drink
today bartender I want what he had you
know okay and then we have does light
stretch uninterruptedly from Andromeda
to Earth you know I mean if you're
talking about particles you can say well
the particles travel so they're all
discreet so they're not connected to
each other why would they travel in a
straight line or in any way for that
matter you know that's one issue on the
one hand but if there're waves the
question does that wave stretch all the
way to your eye you know wave wave wave
wave wave wave no
interruption or is there a sail you know
a little wave packet that just travels
you know through the air through space
or whatever you got to determine that
okay so uh and then is the meteor of
light made of a single piece or is it
made of parts I mean are we talking
about particles are we talking about
single piece meaning I mean if the wave
is made out of a single piece this wave
whatever the wave really is
okay does light Bend warp curve or does
it deflect I mean if you're talking
about photons what do you mean you're
bending a photon what what do you mean
you warped light what do you mean you
warped or bend or curved light are you
saying you curved the photon or you
saying you deflected the photons with
warp
SpaceTime okay so they're not clear
about that they use words of they use
adjectives and they use them for to give
a physical interpretation in which
they're talking about adverbs okay
physical in physics not in ordinary
speech okay adjectives qualify nouns so
if you're going to say curved warped you
know bent they're talking about a
physical the table can be bent yeah or
broken or warped or whatever that's
different than saying that a whole bunch
of photons are traveling in a cured
manner now they're traveling cval
linearly
rectilinearly uh they're deflected you
know you can use any term you want but
make sure you use the right terms that's
why it's an issue of language and these
people are saying oh light is warp what
do you mean light is is word what is
light is light a you know a single solid
thing that you
are or are we talking about the
deflection of photons that has to be
clarified the language is absolutely
essential to understand what these
idiots are saying okay if so what was it
that bent you know right those are the
uh questions you got to ask these people
don't ask me these questions because uh
I don't do math fiz you know so whoever
does math fiz has to defend his position
I defend something
else okay so here we have it uh
illustration of that here goes you can
see are we saying that the wave travels
like a little sailboat or does it extend
all the way to Earth okay that's the
question if it extends it's continues
you know otherwise you you got to tell
me where the wave begins where it
stops okay you see that so it either
travels
or it
extends one more time
[Music]
here okay so you need to know the
beginning and ending of a
wave okay so uh yeah these are the
things that people have to these are the
questions the structural questions the
assumptions the
hypothesis that people have to
question and uh mathematical physics
doesn't have any because they don't have
definitions and they don't have objects
they deal with Concepts which they
converted or morphed or reified into
concrete things into objects and they
treat them as objects You Know Field
Mass energy Etc and they treat them as
physical objects then they
apply adjectives to what in front of us
is
patently a verb so they should be
applying adverbs and they don't they
apply adjectives because an adjective
goes well with a physical interpretation
adverbs talk about motion so they don't
say that something is incessant they say
it's unbounded they don't say that the
or they use the word path which is
ambiguous you can say what do you mean
by path well I mean that it could be you
know a uh a road a highway or it could
be the itinerary of you on that road on
that highway so the highway is curved
you curve no no I don't curve my
itinerary is curvy linear not curved
what's curved is the highway and so you
have to distinguish between warped
curved and bent on the one hand which
are adjectives for objects and
itineraries which or trajectories which
can be deflected or um incessant or
Perpetual they have other qualifiers
which are known as adverbs in physics
you have to determine if you're talking
about an object or a verb you know once
you determine that you got to use an
adjective for these and adverbs for that
that's how it is okay that's
physics okay so uh how do we do it in uh
in rope in under the Rope model here it
is the Rope extends all the way to Earth
okay and then with this we can explain
and here it's only one atom on each side
okay we have gazillions of them but here
again one rope only and you can see why
the moon doesn't fly over way because
it's every atom the Moon is tied to
every atom on Earth and that's why you
can see the moon at all times you're
seeing through these ropes it's the
torsion going in both directions and
there you see the difference between
Quantum and the Rope model one is just
discrete particles and the other one is
interconnected ropes one more time here
you see the Rope one rope only here you
can see different frequencies there okay
the moon going around the earth also
because every rope uh connect every atom
on the moon to every atom on Earth and
there's the difference between quantum
mechanics and what we propose okay
straightforward
okay okay and so here um just in case
for those of you who have doubts more
proof more evidence those of you who
want evidence proof you know here it is
we have Mr Richard Miller and he says
what every atom on Earth is connected to
every atom of you you are also connected
to it let's let's repeat that let's see
if you can get that in your head every
atom on Earth is connected to every atom
of you every atom of you is connected to
every atom on Earth that's what Muller
is saying professor at what UC Berkeley
okay now what part of that did you not
understand it's straightforward let's
repeat it one more time all all at the
same time now
every atom of you is connected to every
atom of Earth every atom of Earth is
connected every atom of you how else can
you explain that unless there's a
physical connector which you cannot see
or
touch okay and you say see touch yeah
because an object a thing is not that
which you can see your touch it's that
which has shape this connector this
mediator this agent that we put in
between atoms has shape but it cannot be
seen or touched